it is a Thanksgiving Thursday and
speaking of generosity let's talk about
the Las Vegas Raiders they play in
Seattle on Sunday but before going up
north it was Turkey Time offensive
lineman for the silver and black having
a straight year ninth straight year of
helping local food banks before it was
Oakland now it's here in Las Vegas this
year they distributed 600 meal boxes to
families in collaboration with Three
Square Food Bank as for the game itself
the Raiders take on the Seahawks Sunday
afternoon at one a game you can watch
right here on 8 news now Sherry
all right thank you so much John well
it's the great food drive it continues
on through December 2nd and we hope that
you can join in and participate and help
make a difference in a teenager's live
project 150 does help feed homeless
teenagers right now you can drop off
non-perishable food items at any Smith's
location members of the 8 news now team
will be live at The Smiths Marketplace
on West Warm Springs Tuesday starting at
five in the morning the great food drive
runs through December 2nd that's a
Friday